Next, we will discuss strategies for allocating space on
mass storage devices to a file. Just like caches
work in terms of units of cache lines or
cache blocks and virtual memory works in terms of pages,
file systems work in terms of blocks also sometimes
called clusters. In the case of a disk, a
block address would need to identify the physical location.
There are different vocabularies here. We'll refer to platter, track
and most specifically, sector. The block address identifies the
starting sector and the block itself might cover several more
sectors, all blocks are of the same size. There are
several strategies for keeping track of which blocks are free
and which are used, one easy way is to keep
a list of free blocks. Another is to use a
bit vector where each bit indicates whether a block is
free or not. There are more complex strategies as well.
Which is more appropriate will depend on the strategies for
assigning new blocks to a file as it grows. We won't
go into those details here. Instead, we will focus on
how a file system keeps track of which blocks belong to
which files and of the ordering of these blocks within
the file. Ideally, we would want a file system that allows
for simple and fast creation and deletion of files. The
simplicity here will help maintain consistency in the face of crashes.
We want flexibility on size, that is, we ant to
be able to handle file sizes large as well as
small, and of course we want an efficient use of
disc space, and we want fast access. Sequential refers to reading
a file in sequence, from start to finish, and random
access refers to jumping around in a file. Specifically, we'll
look at the file allocation table strategy, which was widely
used in the DOS era, and is still used on many
USB devices. And we'll also look at the extended
file format, which is the long time Linux standard.